I'm a sentence you Connor Chapman not
just for this very serious offense of
murder
but also with the two offenses of
attempted murder counts two and three
two offenses of wounding with intent to
cause Grievous bodily harm counts four
and five
an assault occasionally actual bodily
harm count six
and possessing firearm together with
possessing ammunition both with intent
to endanger life counts seven and eight
I must also sentence you for an
offensive handling stolen goods which
concerns the stolen Mercedes A-Class
for reasons it will become clear I will
pass concurrent sentences on all of
these offenses
but the seriousness of all you're
offending will be reflected in the
sentence I impose on count one murder
the sentence of murder is imprisonment
for life
I have to decide
what whether that should be a whole life
or a minimum term which you'll have to
serve
the difference is whether you're
offending is so exceptionally serious in
the context of the gravest of murder
offenses
that you should serve the whole of your
life in custody rather than a very long
term
whilst I'm sure that there are some who
would readily consider that a whole life
term should be imposed
I have concluded that your offending is
on the cusp between a whole life and a
very long minimum term
and in the circumstances I cannot
conclude that a whole life term as a
sentence of Last Resort for the very
gravis of murders must be imposed
the starting point in fixing the minimum
term which is the period that you must
serve in custody before you might seek
to be released is 30 years on count one
I must increase that term
firstly to reflect the factors which
increase its seriousness
and secondly to reflect the other
offenses including two offenses of
attempted murder
I take into account also to The Limited
extent that it provides any mitigation
your age
accordingly I increase the minimum term
to firstly 36 years and secondly up to
48 years which reflects your total
offending
it's understood by you Connor Chapman as
well as those who are observing
it means that you will have to serve 48
years in custody before you could apply
for release
and if you're ever released and
considering your dangerousness that
might never happen you will be on
license for the rest of your life and
subject to recall to prison if you've
breached the terms of that license
I must also impose the sentences to be
served at the same time as your sentence
on count one
on counts two and three be being for
attempted murder
I'm satisfied that each of those
offenses require separate sentences of
imprisonment for life under Section 285
of the sentencing act 2020
there for a schedule 19 offense and you
are a dangerous offender given the
circumstances of these attempted murder
offenses and the murder of Ellie Edwards
they fall within category A2 under the
guideline with a starting point of 30
years which I increase on each to 33
years to reflect the aggravating factors
I have identified in count one
there is little by way of mitigation I
must then fix a minimum term which I set
at 22 years
accordingly the sentences for counts two
and three
are concurrent sentences of imprisonment
for life with a minimum term of 22 years
this means that you'll have to serve
three life sentences concurrently
on counts four and five section 18
wounding with intent they fall within
category A3 of the guideline
adjusting the starting point to reflect
aggravating and mitigating factors I
impose seven years imprisonment
concurrently
on count six section 47 assault which
Falls within category A3 I impose 18
months concurrently
on count seven and eight offenses of
possessing a firearm under possessing
its ammunition both being category 1A
offenses under the guideline I impose 15
years imprisonment concurrently with
each other and all other sentences
handling stolen goods I impose three
years imprisonment concurrently as a
category 2A offense
Connor Chapman stand up
I sent it to you as follows on count 1
to imprisonment for life with a minimum
term to serve in custody of 48 years
less 176 days served on demand
on counts two and three concurrent
sentences of imprisonment for life under
Section 285 the sentencing act 2020 with
a minimum term of 22 years
on counts four and five concurrent
sentences of seven years imprisonment
on count six a concurrent sentence of 18
months imprisonment on count seven and
eighty at seven and eight a concurrent
sentence of 15 years
and for the offense of handling stolen
goods a concurrent sentence of three
years imprisonment he can go down